but we begin tonight with threats
and truth that is the focus of tonight's
angle
[Music]
five years ago
uh speaker gingrich visited taiwan
it was completely wrong the usa should
draw lessons from it instead of making
repeat mistakes
it's now well let me just tell you one
thing
it's 10 am in taiwan and to her credit
nancy pelosi didn't back down when chyna
essentially threatened to shoot her
plane out of the sky
now she's been on the ground for what
about 12 hours or so landing here just
after 10 30 a.m eastern today we're
going to bring you news about the
specifics of her meetings at any moment
now remember trip details have been
largely kept under wraps due to the
security concerns
but by going ahead with this trip nancy
pelosi is defying the white house
and ignoring the threats made by chinese
communist party leadership
china's sovereignty cannot be infringed
and
chinese people cannot be humiliated and
the reunification of china cannot be
stopped the pla
will not
you know stay idle
now think about all those american
companies like nike and all the hedge
funders like larry fink
the billions they make in china it's a
country that considers a brief visit by
nancy pelosi
with a long-time ally like taiwan a
humiliation and then it uses it as a
pretext to activate its military
now speaker pelosi has demonstrated that
supporting the ccp is inconsistent with
modern day liberalism
and when that happened
most in the establishment they didn't
get angry with china
they got angry with pelosi there was no
immediate reason why the speaker had to
go to taiwan there's no change in the
fundamentals of u.s policy right now is
the time to have good relations with
china
open dialogue and not doing anything to
provoke them i wouldn't be poking the
bear right now
don't poke the bear well i was heartened
though to see that mitch mcconnell and
some of the more establishment type
republicans stood up to the prc
i think it's important that the speaker
did go to taiwan
i don't think the chinese
get to tell members of congress
where they can go
now this moment has forced the
establishment to acknowledge
some very unpleasant truths about china
that they've tried to keep hidden for
years
president xi is an evil dictator who
doesn't want to just crush taiwan just
as he crushed hong kong but ultimately
he wants to dominate us as well
yet the biden administration they still
refuse to grasp or respond to this
threat
now this just isn't the opinion of the
angle
listen to obama's former ambassador to
china
poor joe biden he looks weak because he
either told her not to go
it looks weak in the chinese guys or
he's weak because he told her not to go
and she went anyway and that that makes
us look a little bit weak to the chinese
chinese understand strength better than
to people in any other country and they
could smoke smell weakness a hundred
miles away
and weakness is what they're smelling
here
for the week leading up to pelosi
landing in taiwan the pentagon and the
white house were panicking
and waving her off
the fact is they all know
we aren't ready for a conflict with
china
they just didn't want us to know that
but now we do despite our 800 billion
per year in military spending we're just
not prepared for president xi's
challenge
now thanks to china's admission into the
world trade organization 21 years ago in
our idiotic trade policy pre-trump
china now has a larger standing army
than we have
marinate on that for a second so bottom
line
all the establishments coddling of the
ccp has empowered them and weakened us
and now we find ourselves more
vulnerable militarily and economically
and all these supply chain issues we're
dealing with expose how stupid and how
reckless our establishment was
but now isn't the time to cry over all
the spilled milk
if you think we are too dependent on
china for key supplies then it's time
for us to build new supply chains
if you think we need an army that hasn't
been hollowed out by wokeness
then it's time to reform the military
if you think that the chinese are
prepared to sacrifice for their country
and yet we americans are not prepared to
do so for our own
then let's start about how think about
how we can start teaching young people
to love america
instead of hating her
but don't keep pretending that we can
give in to president xi's demands over
and over again without those demands
getting worse today he's telling us who
can visit taiwan tomorrow he may be
telling us what we can say about china
even at home
now this has already happened in the
film hat industry hasn't it
the future of america belongs to the
political movement that best recognizes
the danger of president xi and figures
out the best strategy to keep us all
living from china's vice grip
and by the way don't for a moment fall
in with any of the cynics who say oh we
can't untangle from china at this point
we're too enmeshed with china they're
wrong
we have a system that delivers the
highest standard of living in the world
to over 320 million people of all
different backgrounds and ethnicities
they have a giant prison camp
we're talking about i don't know winnie
the pooh can get you sent away for years
yeah we've been sloppy and yeah we've
made mistakes
but instead of whining about how
hopeless our position is
the time has come for all of us
to live in the truth
about what we're facing
there is just no country that presents a
broader threat
to our ideas
our innovation
and our economic security than china
finally that guy's right about something
and of course xi makes mistakes as well
the more he issues threats the better
america is going to look
if you live in korea or japan or india
or australia or new zealand you should
be thinking
uh oh
we could be next
unless that is the americans are strong
enough to hold them off
so this isn't a day for hand ringing
it's not even a day for recriminations
against all those politicians you know
who you are by the way from both parties
who bollocks the whole china situation
today is a day to come to terms with the
fact that president xi and the ccp are
the single most dangerous threats to us
and the world
and that it's time to change course
before it's too late
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else